toutes les familles du québec vont
pouvoir bénéficier d'un service de dîner
dans leur école à prix modique de nuit
révolution quand on propose des repas
offerts à l'école ça existe déjà il y en
a dans soixante dix pour cent des écoles
primaires au québec a fait qu'ils
changeraient avec le pq c'est qu'il y en
aurait partout on veut n'oublier
personne
être juste maintenant parlons du prix
actuellement un repas traiteur coûtent
plus ou moins 5 dollars
le pq veut lui module i le prix en
fonction du revenu familial
si votre revenu est de plus de soixante
cinq mille dollars comme environ la
moitié des québécois
le report va coûter 5 $ pour vous ça
risque de ne rien changer
le repas traiteur coûte déjà inscrit
mais si vous touchez entre 35 et 65
milles
le repas sera alors de 3 $ et de 1 $
pour ceux qui gagnent moins de trente
cinq mille dollars dans certains milieux
défavorisés il ya des commissions
scolaires qui subventionne déjà la
distribution de repas à un dollar
la commission scolaire de montréal
estime que la moitié des enfants ont des
besoins alimentaires et seulement 18 %
des élèves obtiennent de l'aide
les boîtes à lunch péquiste pourrait
donc répondre à un réel besoin et qui
maintenant est ce que les robots qui
sont actuellement offerts dans les
écoles sont populaires ben y'a une étude
qui a été menée à sherbrooke
la moitié des enfants apporte toujours
un lunch de la maison le tiare varient
durant la semaine entre leurs propres
lunch et leur a pas d'école et seulement
5 % choisissent toujours le dîner offert
à l'école les autres mais ils préfèrent
carrément aller manger à la maison au
fond pour que les reports à faire à
l'école soit adopté et il ya des
directeurs qui nous disent qu'il faut
deux choses d'abord un bon prix mais
surtout un menu de qualité
[Musique]